the floodgates have been opened by the
humiliating endorsement losses last week
for Donald Trump and now former vice
president Mike Pence is trashing the
very president that he served under Mike
Pence is now not mincing words and he is
saying Trump was Reckless and he
endangered my family what a brave former
vice president right sorry that's me
choking on the absurdity of it this
guy's pathetic this guy is pathetic you
had to wait until five days after the
midterm to say what Trump did was
disgusting and he endangered my family
etc etc no the time to say it was right
after the January 6 riots and before the
2022 midterms and Mike Pence is now
taking advantage of the fact that Trump
is as weak as he's been in a long time
and everybody's turning against him not
everybody but many are turning against
them to say the following now it's still
notable
he said this on ABC to David Muir
uh it's still notable because I don't
remember of any modern historical
example of a vice president and a
president turning on each other to this
degree it's emblematic of the
dysfunction that always existed in the
Trump White House here's Mike Pence
members were barricaded inside the house
chamber
and in the middle of it all you can see
that the president has tweeted
2 24 PM the president tweets Mike Pence
didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done and this is a
dramatic pause here the video hasn't
stopped
it angered me
um
but I turned to my daughter who was
standing nearby
right and I said it doesn't take courage
to break the law
takes courage to uphold the law I mean
the president's words were Reckless
it's clear he decided to be part of the
problem
yeah
um
Mike Pence
should have said all of this before
he now found the
testicular fortitude to use a less crass
phrase
to come out and say this
but why not say it before the midterms
dispense feel safe now
because a lot of the trump-backed
candidates failed
it's cowardly to a degree
if you click now I know some of you are
going to say oh but David sir he has a
book coming out and it makes sense to
wait because he doesn't want to hurt the
Republicans that he likes oh I get why
he's waiting trust me I understand why
he's waiting but it's cowardly in the
sense that if Mike Pence really wants us
to believe he is the patriot who puts
country above all else no matter what
then it should be seen as his
responsibility to at the immediate point
at which he believes something as
significant as this was a reckless
president I served under who endangered
me and my family
if that is his belief
you don't wait to strategically time
that that doesn't make any sense unless
you're number one Guiding Light is
actually something different and with
Pence it is always what is best for him
now he's correct I don't deny that what
Pence is saying is accurate Trump was
completely Reckless on January 6th
Trump's actions did and his words did
endanger Pence and his family where they
were you know building a Gallows and
saying hang Mike Pence and they still
hate Pence but Pence is a coward at the
end of the day and uh he should have
been saying this six months ago he could
have been saying this almost two years
ago right 22 months ago when the riots
actually happened so Pence is he setting
up his own run for 2024 we have no idea
at this point in time but he's saying
things that are of course true but he
should have said a long time ago
you already know that you need a VPN to
protect your privacy from your internet
provider from Tech platforms from
hackers and you've seen a ton of ads for
different vpns they seem similar which
one do you choose there's really one
thing I look at can it be independently
verified that the VPN isn't logging your
activity that's why when we were looking
for a VPN sponsor we reached out to
private internet access because private
internet access is the only VPN with a
no log policy that has been proven in
court not once but multiple times their
VPN is 100 open source the code is
public their server networks and
management systems are independently
audited by Deloitte to verify there is
no logging with their new next-gen
server setup it's also one of the only
vpns fast enough for stream gaming and
other activities my audience gets
private internet access for 82 percent
off that's just two dollars and eleven
cents a month plus three months free go
to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link is down
below